seems like we're seeing each other every
few weeks now from the Japan of the G7
to uh to uh when I visited Keith a few
weeks ago to now here but it's a really
important time for us to be always
making sure that we're giving you all
the best support you can it's been an
important time to come together to have
you at NATO
uh there's a there's a path forward and
we're continuing to work on getting all
the support that Ukraine needs during
this incredibly pivotal time as
collectively we stand up not just for
Ukraine but against Russia and
everything is trying to destabilize in
your country and around the world as you
know Canada will always be there for
Ukraine with everything you need and we
will continue to it's great to see you
again thanks for your visit to Ukraine
and thanks for real feeling of of all of
us all our feelings that's really
Canadians helped Ukraine and helped from
the very beginning of full-scale War we
really count on you
people and we are the same and we you
know that we fight for the same values
and my appreciation for all your support
and your government thank you thank you
very much
that we have a conversation today on the
first of NATO and we need your support
I'm sure that will help